[Music]  here  [Music]  there does seem to be ample evidence  that at least raises serious questions  as to whether war crimes are being  committed and i think the international  criminal court is looking at the  situation  [Music]  [Music]  there is a  big battle  and from official sources we received  information right now the  uh small city macariff  and uh  almost  whole airplane  already in the control is ukrainian  soldier  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  oh  [Music]  it is seen to be one of russia's main  targets so everyone here is saying that  they do believe something will happen  we've seen an increase already in  shelling in the area in the last couple  of days but certainly resolve here  remain strong everyone we've spoken to  will tell you that russia will not take  odessa  you